[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans par le
manque d'eau le magazine des temps forts
de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
un mec côté thibault note bon gentil
beau bonjour orione est notre invité
cette semaine est hors berger bonjour
vous êtes député des yvelines porte
parole du groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec nous et dans
l'actualité cette semaine
il ya d'abord ces nouvelles annonces du
gouvernement sur la fiscalité écologique
l'exécutif a défendu quatre mesures
censées répondre à la grogne des
automobilistes confrontés à la hausse du
prix des carburants l'opposition les
jugent insuffisantes
nous reviendrons aussi sur le budget de
l'éducation nationale a adopté mardi par
l'assemblée
un budget en hausse mais qui prévoit
d'importantes suppressions de postes
dans le secondaire les enseignants se
sont mobilisés lundi pour les dénoncer
pendant ce temps le sénat se penche et
lui cette semaine sur le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
déjà voté à l'assemblée
la chambre haute a notamment voté mardi
l'exonération des cotisations salariales
sur les heures supplémentaires enfin
rappelle alors celui du président de
l'assemblée nationale envers les députés
et ne veut plus de chahut et de cris
notamment pendant les questions au
gouvernement
l'image de l'assemblée est en jeu
affirme-t-il et on commence cette
semaine avec la colère contre la hausse
des prix du carburant qui s'est fait
entendre jusqu'au parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les parlementaires de l'opposition ont
profité des questions d'actualité pour
interpeller le gouvernement sur le sujet
et pour tenter de calmer la colère le
premier ministre a fait des annonces
mercredi matin détaillé par le ministre
de la transition écologique françois de
rugy c'était mercredi après midi lors
des questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale on écoute un le chèque énergie
qui va toucher plus de monde
nous arrivons à près de 6 millions de
bénéficiaires
au lieu de 3,6 et une augmentation
moyenne de 50 euros dès le début de
l'année 2019 la prime à la conversion
pour les voitures nous proposons de la
doubler pour les ménages les plus
modestes qui sont ce qu'on appelle les
gros rouleurs ceux qui font plus de 30
km entre leur domicile et leur lieu de
travail
et puis nous aurons également
l'indemnité kilométrique qui pour les
petites voitures
là aussi gros rouleurs que des petites
voitures on ne va pas évidemment
revaloriser l'indemnité kilométrique
pour les grosses voitures
elle sera revalorisée pour les voitures
de moins de quatre chevaux de puissance
fiscale et enfin il n'y aura ni impôts
ni cotisations sociales sur les aides
qui sont versés par des collectivités
locales ou par les employeurs pour les
transports en commun le covoiturage ou
également et d'autres modes de transport
alors berger on le voit le gouvernement
essaie de corriger le tir c'est la
semaine des mea culpa d'ailleurs est-ce
que l'exécutif n'a pas fait une erreur
finalement on n'anticipant pas ça grogne
sur la hausse des prix du carburant est
ce que sa mesure n'arrive pas trop tard
je pense que l'exécutif a raison et a
raison de tenir bon
parce que l'erreur ce serait de renoncer
à enfin voir une fiscalité
environnementale qui va permettre
durablement de changer les comportements
parce que sinon on va continuer à avoir
une dette écologique en fait c'est qu'on
va reporter de génération en génération
et ce qui est quand même assez amusant
de la part des différentes oppositions
qui sont coalisés
autour de ce sujet et autour d'une
grogne qu'ils essayent de faire monter
dans le pays sur la sur la hausse des
carburants c'est que ceux qui hier ont
voté la taxe carbone aujourd'hui
voudrait évidemment qu'elle soit
supprimée ce qui hier plaidait dans le
programme de leur candidat à la
présidentielle pour plus de
responsabilité écologique là on voudrait
mans donc nous on tient bon sur cet
enjeu écologique et on accompagne les
français dans cette transition avec les
annonces qui ont été détaillées par ce
que disent les oppositions et aussi une
partie des français sait c'est qu'ils
s'expriment aussi un doute c'est que
finalement cet acte n'a y pas vraiment
au budget de l'écologie et c'est ce que
disent notamment lé rapporteur du budget
des deux chambres qui montrent qu'une
grande partie du fruit de ces taxes va
au budget de l'état
mais le budget de l'état c'est le budget
de l'ensemble des français qui permet la
solidarité nationale chez vers la
transition écologique vous avez un cap à
des taxes affectées systématiquement sur
ces questions là mais l'idée d'avoir une
fiscalité environnementale c'est de
permettre de changer les comportements
c'est à dire de fléchés vers des
comportements qui sont plus vertueux en
fait et on sait bien où évidemment que
le diesel est beaucoup plus polluant et
a des effets sur notre santé qu'un
certain nombre de français qui meurent
chaque année à cause de ces questions là
et donc plus fléchés vers l'essence ou
le flécher même vers des véhicules
hybrides ou vers des véhicules
électriques et donc on le fait à la fois
par la fiscalité mais aussi par de
l'incitation avec des primes à la
conversion qui ont été notamment élargi
alors justement puisque vous parlez de
cette prime à combien sur l'énergie
élargi 4000 euros mais qui ne concerne
que les 20% de français les plus
modestes
qu'est ce que vous dites du coup aux
classes moyennes qui ne bénéficieront
pas de cette prime mais qui subissent la
hausse des prix du carburant déjà on à
2000 euros pour l'ensemble des foyers là
c'est pas soumis au niveau de revenu et
on a jusqu'à 2000 euros supplémentaires
pour les foyers les plus modestes
avaient même un peu plus loin puisque
quand vous avez un véhicule électrique
sera jusqu'à 6000 euros donc on est
vraiment dans un accompagnement vers ce
cas de plus vertueux donc vous voyez
bien que deux mille euros c'est déjà un
engagement qui est fort on pensait pas
que tu auras un tel succès d'ailleurs et
ça c'est une bonne chose ça veut dire
que les français s'en sont emparés
on aurait pu avoir finalement peu de
français qui auraient eu la possibilité
ou la volonté de changer de véhicule
voix qui a déjà deux
180 mille ménages qui ont eu accès donc
on espère et on estime qu'on aura un
million de foyers qui auront changé de
véhicule dans les cinq prochaines années
qui auront bénéficié de la prime alors
emmanuel macron dit qu'il préfère taxer
la pollution plutôt que le travail
incessant sa philosophie
mais quand on taxe des gens qui prennent
leur voiture pour aller travailler ce
que finalement on ne taxe pas aussi le
travail
vous savez moi c'est mon gars j'habite
dans le sud des yvelines
si je pouvais me passer de prendre ma
voiture je le ferai beaucoup plus
volontiers et donc ça s'est aussi allié
à tout ce qu'on va faire notamment je
pense à la loi mobilité qui va arriver
je pense à la réforme de la sncf qui a
été voté il y a quelques mois à peine
c'est un ensemble cohérent à dire il
faut faire en sorte de que les gens
aient d'autres soirées données d'une
solution alternative au fait prendre
leur véhicule est souvent dans des
territoires dans nos territoires ruraux
les gens n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
prendre leur véhicule
raison pour laquelle la il ya un
accompagnement spécifique qui est fait
c'est ce qui était dit par françois de
rugy
pour ceux qui roulent beaucoup donc 60
kilomètres par jour environ trente
années 30 retour ou là vous avez un
accompagnement spécifique
pareil sur l'indemnité kilométrique et
surtout investissement sans précédent
sur les trains du quotidien
typiquement nous en ile de france ça va
nous changer la vie je pense que
beaucoup de franciliens préférait par
sécurité par risque de fatigue sur la
route par coup aussi et par sensibilité
écologique avoir d'autres chocs sur la
voiture s'était pas toujours le cas
alors une étude a montré que 47 pour
cent des français utilisent la prime à
la conversion pour acheter des véhicules
diesel 46% des véhicules à essence et
une chanson seulement 7% acheter des
véhicules électriques alors faut-il
revoir les critères de la prime à la
conversion nous avons posé la question à
la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
écoutez sa réponse
il me semble très important si cela est
vraiment possible aujourd'hui de revoir
les critères effectivement qui font que
les gens bénéficient de cette prime à la
conversion car l'objectif c'est d'aller
vers des véhicules hybrides ou
électriques en tous les cas plus propre
et le diesel doit clairement disparaître
aujourd'hui nos actes auraient tout
routier
alors faut-il mme lemieux fléchi
finalement cette prime à la conversion
uniquement vers les véhicules
électriques ou hybrides
je pense qu'il faut le faire de manière
progressive quand vous êtes
un véhicule qui a plus de quinze ans et
qui est diesel et vous le changez pour
un véhicule qui est sorti en 2018 et qui
diesel vous savez bien que vous n'avez
pas non plus le même véhicule et l'a
même pollution dont contre l'idée c'est
d'aller de plus en plus vers des
véhicules les moins polluants possibles
donc un diesel récent puis essence puis
ensuite hybrides ou électriques
il faut aussi que ce soit accessible à
l'ensemble des français moi c'est un
appel aussi qu'il faut lancer aux
constructeurs dire on a besoin d'avoir
plus de choix et pour plus de budget
j'ai encore regardé hier dans les
véhicules hybrides notamment on a une
palette de choix qui commence à
s'élargir mais j'aimerais que les
constructeurs accélèrent dans ces choix
là et aussi sur l'électrique et
aujourd'hui encore très cher un dernier
mot sur ce sujet de l'écologie les
données comme la priorité désormais des
français par un certain nombre d'études
est ce que vous pensez que ce thème pour
être la clé des prochaines élections
européennes
je pense qu'en tout cas la question
écologique ça c'est un enjeu que
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne doit pouvoir adresser c'est à
dire parfois on se demande à quoi ça
sert l'union européenne la question
écologique
elle doit pouvoir être au coeur des
politiques communes que l'on a au sein
de l'union européenne parce que si la
france met en place des politiques
ambitieuses notamment comme on est en
train de le faire sur la fiscalité
environnementale l'accompagnement la
transition et que nos pays voisins ne
jouent pas le jeu
et bien il y aura un décalage donc là à
mon avis on doit pouvoir avoir une
politique commune emploie aussi faire
émerger des champions européens qui
travaillent sur ces enjeux de recherche
et développement allez on en vient notre
deuxième thème le budget de l'éducation
nationale
[Musique]
c'est un budget qui peut sembler
paradoxal plus d'argent mais moins de
postes d'enseignants priorité aux
primaires mais moins de professeurs dans
le secondaire des choix que le
gouvernement défend mais qui sont mal
compris par les enseignants le ministre
les a défendu dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale mardi au lendemain
d'une journée de mobilisation de résumer
signé clément méric
il faut remonter à 2011 pour voir une
telle image tous les syndicats
rassemblés sous une seule bannière et un
même mot d'ordre non aux suppressions de
postes dans l'éducation nationale c'est
pas pour nous qu'on fait grave c'est
pour les élèves des et la ville ont
besoin d'être encadrés accompagné au
maximum je le vois ça m'arrivait de
faire cours deux fois avec des classes
où il y avait quatre cinq élèves de
moins dans la classe et on sent toute la
différence
c'est pourtant un budget en hausse que
les députés ont adopté cette semaine 52
3 milliards d'euros soit 800 millions de
plus qu'en 2018
mais les effectifs vont diminuer les
1800 créations de postes dans le
primaire ne compenseront pas les 2650
suppression dans le secondaire les
enseignants voulant redit hier on ne
peut pas supprimer 2650 postes dans le
secondaire
lorsqu'on attend 38 mille élèves
supplémentaires sans prendre le risque
d'affaiblir les objectifs d'éducation
que nous aimerions tous partagé pour
atténuer l'effet des suppressions de
postes jean michel blanquer remise sur
les heures supplémentaires qu'ils
présentent aussi comme une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat mais l'opposition le met
en garde les enseignants ne demande pas
des heures supplémentaires mais plutôt
des moyens humains supplémentaires
les enseignants assurent déjà deux
heures supplémentaires hebdomadaires la
charge de travail ne pourra pas
éternellement augmenter le ministre lui
insiste sur la priorité donnée au
dédoublement des classes de cp ce1 dans
les réseaux d'éducation prioritaire nous
sommes en train de mettre le paquet sur
l'enseignement primaire
bien entendu nous diminuons pas non plus
le budget de l'enseignement secondaire
ne soyons pas caricaturaux nous ont
simplement une augmentation moins forte
ce qu'il faut quand même rappeler en
conclusion c'est que ce budget augmente
plus 1,7 pour cent c'est évidemment une
augmentation est simplement c'est un
budget qui fait des choix qui n'est pas
un budget qui consiste simplement à
faire pleuvoir les moyens de façon à
distingue des choix assumé qui met
l'accent sur
apprentissage des fondamentaux que sont
la lecture l'écriture et le calcul alors
berger que répondez-vous à l'inquiétude
des enseignants exprimé lundi dernier je
réponds en effet que le budget est
évidemment os je réponds aussi qu'il
faut pas regarder tout ça de manière
démesurée
c'est à dire les efforts qu'on demande à
l'éducation nationale comme on les
demande à n'importe quelle
administration aujourd'hui c'est 0 2%
des effectifs 0 2% des effectifs la
masse salariale le nombre de personnel
au sein de l'éducation nationale
c'est la moitié du personnel de
l'ensemble des ministères dans notre
pays donc voyez bien que l'effort qui
est demandé est un effort qui est
extrêmement marginale et qui ne vient
pas en plus limité les moyens puisque
les moyens eux continuent à augmenter
alors sur le primaire mais sur le
secondaire vous supprimer des postes
alors que les effectifs vous me croître
dans les années à venir plus quarante
mille élèves à chaque rentrée est ce
qu'on va avoir des classes surchargées
donc des élèves qui apprennent donc bien
non il n'y a pas de risque honnêtement
de classes surchargées
on estime à peu près que le volume de
d'élèves supplémentaires qu'on va voir
mais parce que la démographie change
tout simplement ses environs dans chaque
collège un élève en plus toutes les
trois ou quatre classes
c'est ça l'effectif supplémentaires donc
ça reste quand même extrêmement limitée
et ça ne justifiait pas qu'on maintienne
le même niveau d'enseignants ou qu'on
leur demande c'est des choix qui sont
faits et des choix qu'on assume on
assume de dire qu' il faut réformer
l'ensemble des champs l'éducation
nationale ça va de l'école maternelle
qui va devenir enfin une véritable école
d'apprentissage du langage notamment
l'école primaire avec le paquet en effet
sur les savoirs fondamentaux parce qu'on
l'a un peu trop oublié ces derniers
temps il ya eu un un excès d'idéologie à
l'école et dans la manière avec laquelle
les ministres de l'éducation nationale
abordait leur fonction là avec jean
michel blanc car on a un ministre qui a
orienté vers les résultats et les
résultats de nos élèves
alors on a entendu jean michel blanquer
redire que ces suppressions de postes
dans le secondaire seront notamment
compensée par des hausses des heures
supplémentaires certains enseignants
affirment ne pas pouvoir en faire plus
on ne pas vouloir pour certains en faire
plus c'est ce que vous assumez de leur
dire qu'ils vont devoir faire des
efforts l'effort qu'on demande
c'est encore une fois un effort qui
mesure et c'est à dire c'est une à deux
heures supplémentaires et ça dépend
encore une fois des effectifs qui
existeront dans les différents
établissements scolaires
c'est aussi un pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire qui est rendu aux
enseignants et ça c'est quand même
extrêmement important on a besoin de
mieux rémunérer les enseignants
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait pour les
enseignants dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire dans les rep et les rêves
plus on a mis le paquet dans ces
établissements là en dédoublant les
classes en cp ce1 alors tout le monde
nous disait que c'était impossible etc
objections aujourd'hui tout le monde se
félicite que ce soit les associations
parents d'élèves familiale les
enseignants et puis même les enfants
quand on leur demande et en plus cela on
va mieux rémunérer les enseignants alors
le budget de l'éducation nationale
globalement et donc aux deux de 800
millions en même temps il y aura moins
d'enseignants donc où vont aller les
moyens encore une fois je n'ai déjà il
ya plus d'enseignants en primaire ça a
été rappelé dans votre sujet il y en a
un peu moins sur l'enseignement
secondaire
et puis c'est ensuite plus de moyens sur
la manière avec laquelle les
apprentissages pourront être mis en
place quand on parle de mieux rémunérer
les enseignants c'est plus de moyens
pour les rémunérer quand on parle d'or
supplémentaires
c'est plus de moyens pour rémunérer les
enseignants
quand on met en place le dispositif de
voir fait c'est plus ou moins c'est
aussi plus de moyens de soutien aux
collectivités locales
c'est le plan mercredi qui a été mis en
place il faut évidemment accompagner les
collectivités locales pour le faire pour
que toute la charge ne repose pas sur
elle et je pense que c'est un effort
partagé qui ai demandé alors au menu de
la séance au sénat cette semaine le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sénat a donné son feu vert à des
mesures voulues par le gouvernement
comme l'exonération l'exonération des
cotisations salariales sur les heures
supplémentaires
il en revanche imprimé sa marque sur
d'autres sujets notamment la défense des
retraités marie plat mouche c'est sous
de bons auspices que la majorité de
droite et du centre au sénat a accueilli
le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale 2019 avec en premier
lieu
l'exonération des cotisations sur les
heures supplémentaires pour les salariés
du privé comme du public censé améliorer
le pouvoir d'achat
autre point clé adoptée après quelques
modifications
la transformation du crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi en réduction de
cotisations sociales pour les employeurs
un dispositif favorable aux entreprises
mais le sénat a aussi marqué plus
clairement le texte de son empreinte en
votant notamment la hausse de 40 % de la
contribution exceptionnelle des
mutuelles pour l'année 2019
cette hausse représente un coût de plus
d'un milliard d'euros pour les
complémentaires insoutenable pour le
gouvernement mais la haute assemblée
persiste et signe
quand on sait aussi qu'il ya 20 à 25%
suivant le cas de frais de gestion
bon j'en appelle ses one shot a quand
même la proposition que nous faisons
j'en appelle effectivement à
l'engagement citoyen responsable de ces
organismes
mais ce que l'on retient de l'examen de
ce texte ce sont les nombreux dossiers
liés plus spécifiquement territoire et
sur lesquels les sénateurs sont montés
au créneau sur l'exonération des
travailleurs saisonniers l'embauchent
des pompiers volontaires ou encore la
taxation du rhum à la clé de véritable
passe d'armes
la france a protégé sa production
viticole son vin et la taxe est très
faiblement
pour des raisons que l'on comprend et
j'ai du respect pour cette profession la
france c'est le vin nous dans nos pays
c'est le rom le vote solennel sur
l'ensemble du texte aura lieu mardi
prochain alors berger le sénat donc voté
l'exonération des cotisations salariales
sur les heures
plémentaires la mesure coûtera à peu
près deux milliards en année pleine en
2017 une étude de l'office
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques estimait qu'une telle mesure
pourrait supprimer 19 mille emplois à
l'horizon 2022
est ce que c'est de l'argent bien
dépensé oui c'est de l'argent bien
dépensé ça rejoint le tout premier sujet
qu'on avait évoqué ensemble c'est à dire
arrêter de taxer le travail et en effet
faire le choix de taxer plus la
pollution
c'est une politique qui est cohérente il
faut mieux rémunérer ceux qui
travaillent dans notre pays
c'est un choix de pouvoir d'achat qu'on
a fait et je pense qu nettement c'était
une mauvaise idée de la part de françois
hollande de revenir sur cette mesure qui
avait été prise à l'époque par nicolas
sarkozy dans une logique de balayer tout
ce qu'avait fait son prédécesseur
c'était une mesure qui était importante
pour les français et c'est un gain de
pouvoir d'achat pour eux alors le sénat
a été très actif sur la défense des
retraités 1 il est notamment revenu sur
le quasi gel des pensions de retraite il
veut rétablir l'indexation des pensions
sur l'inflation
est ce que les sénateurs n'ont pas
raison quand ils disent que le
gouvernement fait peser trop d'effort
sur les retraités ce qui est toujours
intéressant c'est de voir aussi la
cohérence des propositions d project
hier soir ont rejeté en séance à
l'assemblée nationale
et j'entendais systématiquement nos
collègues et leur dire qu'il fallait
absolument avoir une ligne ferme en
matière d'économies budgétaires et ne
pas continuer à aller vers une forme de
gabegie et dans le même temps il ne
cesse de proposer des mesures dont on
sait qu'elles ont un coup majeur pour
pour l'état donc à un moment il ya une
question de cohérence
ce qu'on dit aux retraités c'est déjà y
a pas eu de gel des pensions il ya eu
une augmentation des pensions de +0 3%
ce qui est un engagement fort et très
loin de l'inflation qui est en deçà de
l'inflation je vais pas le nier ce
serait vous mentir que le nier par
contre on veut pas dire qu a eu un gel
ya quand même une augmentation qui a été
fait des retraits de +0 3% ce qui n'est
pas rien et ce qu'il ya un coup quand
même pour le budget de l'état donc pour
le budget de l'ensemble des français
et ensuite il ya des mesures
d'accompagnement importante pour les
personnes les plus fragiles ça aussi
c'est des choix politiques comme vous le
disais sur l'éducation nationale ont
fait des choix et on les assume et le
choix c'est de dire il faut plus
accompagnés soit dur donc plus besoin
donc c'est une augmentation très
importante
du minimum vieillesse notamment et puis
c'est des engagements dans le plfss qui
sont importants qu'on avait voté déjà à
l'assemblée nationale je pense au reste
à charge 0 c'est majeur c'est
probablement la plus grande réforme
sociale qu'on pourra faire dans ce
quinquennat c'est à dire faire en sorte
qu'ils aient plus aucun français qui
renoncent à se soigner
je pense qu'on est tous en tant que
député sénateur on reçoit des français
qui nous disent je n'ai pas les moyens
d'avoir des lunettes je n'ai pas les
moyens d'avoir une prothèse auditive ou
ou dentaires là ils n'auront plus à
renoncer au sol est que cela suscite des
inquiétudes notamment sur le prix des
complémentaires est ce que vous pouvez
garantir aux français que le prix de
leur complémentaire n'augmentera oui
c'est un engagement très clair qui a été
pris devant le président de la
république par notamment les mutuelles
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'augmentation du
prix des complémentaires que c'est un
engagement très clair et très ferme qui
a été pris on met en place un
observatoire des prix pour vérifier
l'application de cette mesure donc à une
grande vigilance a été rappelé aussi par
agnès buzyn évidemment la ministre et
nous mêmes en tant que parlementaire on
est en charge l'évaluation de la loi et
donc je peux vous dire que là on va être
très vigilants alors dernier point le
sénat droite et gauche unanime 1 est
revenu mercredi sur la suppression de
l'exonération des cotisations pour
l'emploi des travailleurs saisonniers
voté à la majorité à l'assemblée le
gouvernement ne devrait-il pas renoncer
à cette mesure qui est dénoncé par les
agriculteurs
on avait beaucoup avancé déjà à
l'assemblée nationale parce que nous
avons permis avec main sur ce qu'on a
appelé le thé au 2e
honnêtement d'avoir quelque chose qui
était un véritable équilibre pour les
différents territoires et je pense
notamment aux arboriculteurs aux
viticulteurs qui étaient les premiers
concernés par par ce type de mesure
je trouve que l' équilibre qu'on a eu à
l'assemblée nationale est un équilibre
qui est très satisfaisant pour nos
territoires et qui est aussi très
satisfaisant pour le budget de l'état et
moi je pense aux deux et je pense qu
nettement le compromis de l'assemblée
est acceptée je vous n'allez rien
retenir des mesures votées par le sénat
puisque le plfss va revenir à
l'assemblée dans les prochains jours n'y
a pas de raison qu'ils rien qui puisse
qui puisse être retenu en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que sur des
mesures aussi importantes et le cap qui
a été fait notamment sur la question des
retraites c'est sûr qu évidemment là on
va pas y revenir après dans le détail
oui il ya des choses qu'il faut faire je
vous en avais un sujet sur la question
de l'outre-mer c'est un débat qu'on a eu
par exemple sur certaines taxation pour
l'autre main et je pense que là
il ya des avancées qui ont eu lieu au
sénat et qu'on pourra reprendre a semblé
aller on en vient notre dernier thème ce
rappel à l'ordre des députés sur leur
comportement dans l'hémicycle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la bienséance pendant les séances et
le message du président de l'assemblée
nationale à ses troupes le président qui
a écrit aux députés cette semaine pour
leur dire qu'il sévirait désormais en
cas de non respect du règlement
à l'origine de ce rappel à l'ordre les
cris d'un député pendant une séance de
questions au gouvernement il y a deux
semaines mathieu des moulins c'était il
y a deux semaines dans l'hémicycle de
règlement d'inscrire ce long procès
verbal ça fait plusieurs fois que je
demande
dégoûté les orateurs calculs voire le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand entre dans une colère
noire contre un député les républicains
un peu brouillée dans un courrier
adressé aux 577 députés
il promet de serrer la vis et impose la
discipline il n'est pas tolérable
notamment que certains troubles
l'intervention d'un orateur au point
qu'ils doivent s'interrompre n'écoute
pas les réponses des ministres ou
préfèrent s'asseoir sur les marches de
la salle des séances plutôt qu'à leur
siège
le règlement de l'assemblée prévoit des
sanctions pour les comportements qui
trouble l'ordre de la séance ou violent
ces dispositions
je vous informe que j'entends désormais
appliquer ces sanctions chaque fois que
les circonstances l'exigeront dans son
viseur notamment les coups d'éclat de
certains députés d'opposition sur la
baisse des apl le port d'un maillot pour
défendre le football associatif ou
encore les pancartes brandies lors du
départ de manuel valls
le recadrage est saluée évidemment par
la majorité
nous avons un grand président de
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi par des
députés parfois adepte des coups d'éclat
en séance ça ne me gêne absolument pas
et c'est normal parce que les français
nous regarde
ouais je prends l'impression qu'on soit
seulement visé moi j'avais l'impression
c'était plus globale que ça et je trouve
que il manquait je vous dis la manière
dont le gouvernement réagit répond qui
est qui est souvent très méprisante de
l'assemblée nationale selon la gravité
des faits les sanctions pour manquement
au règlement peuvent aller du simple
rappel à l'ordre à une exclusion
temporaire de l'assemblée avec retenues
sur indemnités alors berger ce rappel à
l'ordre est il le bienvenu on a quand
même un peu l'impression ces députés
d'opposition qui sont visés il n'ya pas
une volonté de museler le débat je suis
pas certaine qu'il ya un vrai débat
quand on est au point de ne plus en
temps
ce que disent les orateurs parfois on
s'en rend pas compte qu'on est
téléspectateurs par rapport à la manière
de simplement avec laquelle le son est
pris en compte dans l'hémicycle moi je
peux vous dire qu'étant dans l'hémicycle
il ya un certain nombre de moments où je
n'entends plus mes collègues qui
s'exprime
je n'entends pas le gouvernement qui
s'effrite et mes collègues
quelles que soient les bancs sur
lesquels il siège est à dire qu il soit
dans la majorité ou dans l'opposition on
arrive à des moments où c'est absolument
inaudible et donc quelle est la qualité
du débat quand on n'entend ni les
questions ni les réponses je pense qu'à
un moment on est quand même responsable
on doit l'être en tout cas de l'image
qu'on renvoie à l'extérieur et je suis
pas certaine que les français soient
très fiers de leurs parlementaires
quand il voit ce genre de spectacle
richard ferrand rappelle qu'il est aussi
interdit de téléphoner de filmer ou de
photographier à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle vous vous respecter cette
règle c'est m'est déjà arrivé
photographiant notamment des résultats
de ce scrutin public pour être honnête
téléphoner dont je m'arrêterai pas
téléphoner dans l'hémicycle non mais ça
peut faire sourire et je pense juste
qu'un moment d'un présent de l'assemblée
nationale qui veut faire en sorte que
cette institution soit respectée pour
qu'elle le soit il faut aussi qu'elle
soit respectable dans la manière avec
laquelle les débats sont organisés même
si c'est d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine merci thibault on y retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour d'autres
actualités parlementaire
[Musique]